les goûts
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous emmène au coeur des
marais de bourges à la rencontre d'un
couple de maraîchers qui oeuvre pour
préserver ce patrimoine naturel
exceptionnel installé ici depuis près de
dix ans jean claude et régine cultive
sème des légumes des fleurs mais ils
s'aiment toujours aussi ému on va parler
d'amour dans les marais de ceux qui le
peuple et entretiennent son histoire
et de ce qui laisse des pièges aussi et
jean-claude
le ratuf faut pas laisser dans la cour
comme ça où
[Musique]
nous y sommes le paradis d'origine entre
et c'est ouvert attention aux fautes
d'orthographe les photographes
volontaire
bonjour régine bonjour merci de
m'inviter de m'ouvrir les portes de son
paradis tout à fait alors vous êtes
arrivé quand ici dans les marais on a
pris notre première parcelle en 2012
qu'on a appelé les dell après la
deuxième parcelle celles ci on l'a
appelé le paradis
des fans de vanessa paradis c'est
l'intervention
et le troisième que jean claude a appelé
k-now vu son âge ici dit c'est la
dernière terre que je vais et travailler
je suis pas sur moi mais en forme est
encore entouré par la nature comme ça
sans station 40 ans oui c'est possible
ou alors une passion pour le jardin une
passion pour la nature mais aussi une
passion pour la poésie j'ai lu vos
ardoise à l'entrée on va faire un tour
comme ça on troyenne en balade tu te
fait découvrir la qualité des marais
celle ci je laime beaucoup parce qu'en
fait c'est pour jean-claude si j'étais
jardinier je ferai pouces et une fleurs
en forme de coeur elle serait pour ma
jardinières la fleur c'est tout l'amour
de mon coeur qu'est ce que c'est donc
c'est tout ce que je vis avec jean
claude et si ça passe entre les mains de
de cloclo si j'étais jardinier
réponse est d'une fleur
bleue de 15 heures elles sont mises en
lumière voilà c'est tout c'était mon
interprétation de 10 mo c'est normal on
a rejoint de jean-claude d'accord a mis
encore des montants déposés ici pas de
réseau juste de suite des oiseaux
référence au rappeur ni ce cas que vous
écoutez tous les jours y as tu vu lui on
élude un tollé à bordeaux
on a super très bonne gestuelle très
bonne gestuelle du régime
toujours en action jean-claude il ne
s'arrête jamais uno jean-claude hausse
et une magnifique jean-claude comme on
est sûre qu'est le jardin c'est quoi son
nom fut l'un on est les dance que les
dance et le sait le départ de l'histoire
nous étions en difficulté de couples
tous les deux et donc on a décidé de
faire un break en faisant
un pèlerinage direction de saint jacques
de compostelle
et c'est là qu'on s'est rencontré sur le
chemin alors c'était quand même temps
que qu'elle dure cette bonne histoire
d'amour aux 22 ans
que du bonheur
je veux te montrer une fleur qui est
très odorante cdu sur un gars
on sentait aussi à la maison voici une
caméra on peut sentir les odeurs
s'entendent écran je m en confiance
alors ça bulle est allé travailler à
bercy encore une autre récompense dit
résolue vers luanda
donc c'est jean claude qui a fabriqué
ces bombes oui c'est ici tout pour vous
poser ne tourne autour des fois on est
là on amoureux
filmés ou alors on va citer 1 cette fois
ci tu es en chansons les amoureux qui se
bécotent sur le banc des marais des
bandes et malgré le bond des marais vod
côté 1
c'est pas trop quand même on est sur
france 3
[Musique]